[Music]
this week on
forward I think it's important that
people understand that to be an
impactful to be a profoundly impactful
third party we don't have to be the
dominant party we don't have to have a
majority you know just a few votes that
are genuinely able to coales and do what
do what's right for America could make a
huge difference in the functionality of
our entire nation we need candidates who
can solve local problems as well
a good mayor is worth his or her weight
in gold you know what I mean a good
school board as a parent I mean I've got
chan in public school like a good school
board it's worth it's weight and
[Music]
gold it is my pleasure to welcome back
to the podcast former lieutenant
governor of the state of Massachusetts
former president of Babson College of
brand new executive chair of the forward
party Carrie Healey welcome back Carrie
thank you Andrew it's great to be back
in this position working with you yeah
you are uh exactly what forward has been
looking for in an executive chair we're
going to talk a little bit about that
role and your vision uh for
2024 um now those of you who are Avid
listeners to the podcast uh Carrie came
on last year when she joined forward as
a board member so you I'm not going to
rehash her extensive
awesome history there in many ways this
could be like Carrie Healey uh part two
so if you want to check out part one
just uh you know click on the archives
um but let's give people a very brief
refresher um about what brought you to
forward so so Andrew I came to forward
because I had for many many years been
feeling that the the two-party system
wasn't working working for me and then
suddenly it really wasn't working for
America Wasing for everyone so it's one
thing if I personally would prefer to
have uh an alternative to the
Republicans and the Democrats but it
it's a different thing when you start
seeing the two parties pulling the
country apart really really harming the
fabric of our nation and our culture and
and our our care for one another uh in
the way that that this two-party system
is doing now so for years uh I was what
would you could have char ized as a a an
establishment Republican who was a
Northeast style Republican in
massachusett Mass Republican a
Rockefeller Republican a weld Republican
you know the kind of person who is uh
very concerned about budgets very
concerned about fiscal responsibility
and making sure that government is
efficient and effective but at the same
time would like to see a lot more
compassion in our social policy you know
than it was always exercised when you
were just keep keeping your your eye on
that budget all the time and and I
didn't like to see how social policy and
and and those sort of social issues had
become so prominent in the uh in the
conservative rhetoric uh to the extent
that marriage equality and any kind of
flexibility around um Reproductive
Rights was really being squeezed out and
I had long been a a supporter for
Reproductive Rights and I was an early
uh person to embrace uh marriage
equality or or some sort of expression
of of of that you know for all of our
communities and so I was hoping that the
Republican Party would moderate with me
and they didn't instead they went the
opposite no wonder you felt homeless
Carrie gez you're a pro-choice prog gay
marriage uh compassionate person who
likes the numbers to work out and you're
like
huh this isn't working for me anymore
right so so I felt I felt alienated
progressively alienated from my party
after you know 2012 and and I began in
2016 really thinking about what would it
take you know to have an alternative
that would work for the people of
America because I I saw this growing
group of Independence and now as as you
know it's it's
49% of the voting public in America
doesn't want to be a Republican or a
Democrat they want to have a choice
they're trying to find a candidate that
somehow approximates what they believe
and they can't find it consistently on
one side or the other and so really
Independents are the majority now of you
the majority party of America and yet
they don't disfranchise majority Carrie
we're looking
up look at what happened look at what
just happened in New Hampshire yeah you
we had a a a completely dysfunctional
primary system first of all uh the
Democrats boycotted it you know the the
you know incumbent
president completely boycotts it um
there have been no debates on on the
Democratic side um on the Republican
side the the debates were a farce
because the leader uh
refused up just tried to pretend that it
was a side show um that that allowed
people to think that the Democratic
process was moving forward while in fact
you know there was no intention of
allowing that process to go forward or
or legitimating that in any way and you
know concern is that the two candidates
that came out of that primary were
people who have not debated who have not
presented themselves uh you to the
American public in in a traditional
democratic way uh in terms of democratic
process and and most of the people who
wanted to vote in that primary were
Independence and they had to figure out
what to do so so I came to forward
thinking this is an opportunity to that
where these three groups you know that
had all been looking for democratic
reform who'd all been working in that
third party space um wanted to coales
and and there are a number of other
groups I think who could coales with us
as well um to start building out this
alternative for those disenfranchised
voters who were probably showing up in
New Hampshire just going what do I do
today how you know how do I how do I
make my vote count yeah I I I tried to
uh spell out just how um
unrepresentative our primary system is
right now Carrie and so I found that
maybe 530,000 people have cast votes in
two states Iowa and New Hampshire uh in
a country of 340 million let's say so
you know that that comes down to um less
than one fifth of 1% of Americans have
voted and then they say it's over it's
over yes these are our nominees it's
over but but in truth it's over because
we we have a system now that allows this
to happen and and so they're they're not
wrong that it's over but it shouldn't be
um well we can go into what's going on
in the primaries um but the the the
system really uh isn't about the voice
of the people anymore it's not not about
democracy as you say it's like not about
even people showing up to debates uh
like that there's this this very uh
unrepresentative party Machinery um that
is saying here are your choices and
people are increasingly frustrated and
fed up and so you're seeing people
trying to build Alternatives um you know
like us I mean we're not participating
in the presidential in that fashion
um but we certainly understand the
frustration a great deal um so I I think
that uh your story is I'm sure familiar
to a lot of people watching or listening
to this um you know like they could be
someone on the Democratic side who are
like you know what I don't feel very
well represented or heard but could
certainly be someone on the Republican
side um what I refer to as the
traditional or sane wing of the
Republican party that's not a fan of
trump and you know I I dare say that you
have a lot of friends who are in that
camp um so since we're not going to be
focused on the presidential in my
opinion for very smart reasons and the
way our presidential system works right
now is you're likely to empower the
opposite of
yourself like um so uh what does Ford
want to do in 24 since this is obviously
an enormous year yeah this is this is a
a difficult time for us right now
because we both want to have our
long-term goals and we don't want to
lose any momentum working toward those
long long-term goals but we realize that
the situation right now requires action
I think everyone feels this you know
really strong call to action in 2024
because what we see happening in front
of our face is not acceptable and and is
a real threat to democracy and so the
question is what what role can we play
as a nent party that isn't ready to to
field a candidate who could run and win
you know in the presidential race and if
we ran and didn't win as you mentioned
we would probably ultimately be tipping
the election in what we would consider
to be the wrong direction so I think you
know so we're very very conscious of the
fact that we don't want to be a spoiler
we don't want to do anything in 2024
that could you know be in any way
construed as you know causing us to move
in an anti-democratic Direction so what
can we do uh we have both a short-term
strategy and a long-term strategy our
short-term strategy is called the
reverse coattail strategy and I love the
reverse coattail strategy coattails okay
so the reverse coattail strategy
leverages the fact that there are 500
and and how is it 30,000 530,000 down
ballot seats uh below the the president
and the vice president uh election and
70% of those run un unopposed and
another 10% of it just goes unfilled and
so yeah which is nuts because you know
if you think about how dependent our
country is on those volunteers on people
coming forward and saying that they will
you know give their time their energies
their talents to help run the country
the fact that we need a half a million
people to step up and help run the
country and it's just not happening or
just the bare minimum of of the number
of people who we need are stepping up um
is is really sad and so we we hope you
know as as the forward party to enable
and encourage uh any number of people to
step forward in their local communities
whether it's running for school board or
planning board or running for mayor or
city counselor whether it's running for
your state legislature in many states
that can even be a part-time position
and and there are just innumerable
places where you can contribute and
we're hoping that that forward candidate
becomes the ideal Civic leader and that
that is the kind of person who brings
respon responsible voters with them to
the uh to the ballot so for example if
you or I were running for city counselor
in our town uh we would undoubtedly have
a number of friends who are like-minded
who would come out and and vote for us
because they think of us as responsible
people who are going to do the right
thing for our community and that's what
we're looking for that's the reverse
coattail strategy so we're hoping that
all those people who are perhaps
registered Independence and and who are
discouraged by what's happening and who
might not show up and vote for whatever
the best outcome is for America will be
motivated if they have
candidates friend a friend someone they
know and trust on the ballot and once
they're in that ballot you know once
they're there voting they're going to
vote the whole you know spectrum of
candidates but they might be drawn there
because a candidate who they know
decided to run for local office and and
we're hoping that by filling those we
can really get the turnout uh to be much
more robust among the sensible people
who are the majority of
America this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn using the internet without
expressvpn is a little like walking your
dog in public without a leash most of
the time it might work out but then that
one time your dog could run away or get
dog it's better to take a little bit of
care especially when it's as simple as
using expressvpn when I log on to the
internet I just click on expressvpn and
I get beamed on through an encrypted
Network through a server someplace I
have no idea where it is but then no one
else does either it's great they can't
track you they can't buy and sell your
data you know it's secure and you can
get content from other parts of the
world so you can be kind of
international and Cosmopolitan if that
sounds good good to you right now you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
free at expressvpn.com
yangang that's
expressvpn.com
[Music]
we all know that the national election
is probably not going to be decided by
uh folks in New York or California or
Massachusetts it's going to be decided
by voters in Wisconsin Arizona Georgia
Nevada Pennsylvania and so the reverse
coil strategy is about getting dozens
hundreds of local candidates in those
swing states to run for local office and
then if they draw let's say 50 San
voters uh with them a piece and you had
300 candidates in those swing States you
might boost the sane non-extremist vote
by 15,000 in a race that might get
decided by 50,000 uh the same way that
2020 got decided by 43,000 we have a
very bizarre system where uh out of the
tens of millions of votes cast um it's
really going to come down to a handful
of votes in a handful of Swing States a
few places and it always does it always
does and so it is it is really important
um for everyone to vote in this upcoming
election certainly everyone listening to
this podcast everyone interested in in
the sorts of things that we're
discussing they you must vote you must
get out and you have to think about is
there a way that I could contribute for
example by being a candidate as well
yeah so uh we're going to be recruiting
and enlisting dozens maybe even hundreds
of local candidates uh particularly in
swing States and in states where forward
is very active but anywhere uh so if
that resembles you and you are listening
to this do go to fordp party.com click
on your local state chapter and reach
out to us uh we have resources available
uh and uh even folks like me and
lieutenant governor Healey and uh
Governor Christy Todd Whitman and John
Kingston and Chris Nova selich uh who's
going to be doing something interesting
this cycle um what we're all going to
try and help you make the case to your
local community and we think we can we
can do a couple things one we might get
someone awesome elected locally but two
we might draw uh the right kind of voter
to the polls to avert a very very bad
outcome in November yeah and and our
goal is to get at least 300 of these
candidates nationally but to get them
definitely in those swing States in
particular and you know 300 should be
the floor you know we'd love to have
many more you know but um but but we we
want to at least get going and and the
now for the longer term strategy which
is you know really much more interesting
is a lot of these candidates are
actually interested in running for
congress and and so we can see that over
time we could build up a small small
group of forests uh in Congress uh and a
group of only five to 10 could make such
a difference if Congress continues to be
so evenly divided as it is today so you
know the fulcrum strategy which is a
longer term strategy is having that
power in Congress of a few Independents
who have common beliefs and who could
actually be the deciding factor in
choosing every Speaker of the House in
making sure which bills pass and which
ones don't you know just a few votes
that are genuinely able to coales and do
what do what's right for America could
make a huge difference in the
functionality of our entire nation and
so we are in particular interested um in
having good candidates who want to step
forward and take the risk of running for
congress because the sooner we could
create that that cohort that caucus of a
forests uh in Congress I think the
better uh America is going to be yeah I
joke all the time Carrie uh how many US
senators would it take to uh form this
kind of folr and they think about it for
a second and they think too and it's
like yeah
two two maybe even one you know and and
literally fewer than a dozen in in the
house Congress sure yeah yeah and and
there are there are uh opportunities uh
you know there are going to be people
running um even as independent this
cycle um and and so this is to me a very
achievable goal and vision particularly
as more and more Americans get fed up uh
with this increasingly dysfunctional
unrepresentative two party system system
I think it's important that people
understand that to be an impactful to be
a profoundly impactful third party we
don't have to be the dominant party we
don't have to have a majority totally in
the house we just have to have enough so
that we always have to be consulted so
that we can always be a sanity check on
what's going on we can always sanity
maybe we should call ourselves the
fulcrum of Sanity Carrie but I I joke
all the time that we don't need 51% what
do we need Maybe five six seven eight%
uh and if we get to that level we
actually can help turn things around and
I think that that's achievable and I
think that people can look at that and
and see that that's achievable people
pour money into uh
Congressional and and you know there but
there are congressional races all over
the country people get very uh you know
focused on uh supporting Congressional
races in places where um where it's
expensive to do but we could focus
anywhere in the country anywhere there's
a seat that could be uh transformed into
a for a SE um we we can focus on that
and so uh I I think this is a more
affordable practical and doable you know
genuinely achievable strategy than uh
virtually any political strategy that
I've seen yeah yeah we can be
opportunistic you know we can go to some
District that no one has ever heard of
or cares about but it's cheap and it's a
good opportunity and you know a vote's a
vote exactly and and you know when you
think about the the people who've made
the difference um in the Senate you know
it's it's you know someone from Alaska
it's someone from you know from from
Maine yeah you know it's it's it's
completely random it has does not have
to do with the geography it has to do
with the
votes hey y'all if you know me you know
I'm not that handy in the kitchen and I
have become a huge believer and booster
of factor Factor's delicious ready to
eat meals make eating a joy it's so fast
you just Pop That Thing 2 minutes later
and you are eating a restaurant quality
healthy meal making you feel excellent
about yourself my favorite is the turkey
chili with zucchini and there is so much
more to choose from you never get tired
of it it fits any budget it's fast
healthy it is going to be the new factor
in your life yes I'm a fan head to
factor meals.com
sl50 and use code Yang 50 to get 50% off
your first box and two free wellness
shots per box while subscription is
active that's code y50 at factor
meals.com
y50 to get 50% off your first box get
Factor today it's going to change the
way you
eat
[Music]
yeah let's take advantage of our Bizarro
system um now some people listening to
this are are having their interest peak
they're like what um so what defines a
forwarded candidate uh for if people
want to to see whether it might be a fit
for them so we're doing two things that
are really interesting first of all we I
can I can give you the the rough
outlines
of of what we're looking for in
candidates and I think that people to
some degree can look at you and me and
Christy Whitman and and and others who
who've run uh who are on the board and
say okay I think I understand what a
Ford candidate stands for but first and
foremost we're interested in
strengthening democracy and defending
democracy we believe in the Constitution
we believe in rule of law you know we
believe that everyone is equal under the
law and should be treated equally under
the law you know we believe that there
should be open primaries so so that PE
the best people can emerge from that
primary system uh a number of people uh
in forward work very hard for rank
Choice voting or you know top five
voting or however you know whatever the
the phrases are for this but some system
of voting that allows people who aren't
part of that party system to rise up uh
and some kind of system that allows the
the primaries to be more civil uh to be
more positive than they are today as
opposed to win or take all so so F the
first part of who the our candidates are
is really that support for democracy
Democratic reforms anti-gerrymandering
and so forth um the second part is that
we want collaborative problem solvers we
want people who genuinely want the
trains to run on time and it to be on
budget we want people who are looking
for the best Solutions not just their
Solutions and sometimes those Solutions
might be ones that have been floated by
the Republicans or by the Democrats or
maybe they're entirely new and no one
has ever heard of this solution before
and it doesn't really fit in any bin but
it's a good solution and we should think
about it and so we want open-minded
problem solvers and I've been so
impressed when I've been out talking to
the people who are involved with Ford on
a state level that we are attracting
that sort of person you know really
thoughtful really hardworking and and
intelligent people who are saying how
can I make Society better how can I make
my community better and and solve those
those key issues that are that are
problems and if you think about it most
of our problems are really local
problems if we on a local level had
great schools and Safe Streets and you
know nice parks to take our kids and
dogs to and you know felt that we were
being well represented had a good
Hospital there locally most of us would
feel like our lives were pretty good and
so you know it's not all at that
National level we need candidates who
can solve local problems as well as as a
good May is worth his or her weight in
gold you know what I mean a good school
board as a parent I mean I've got chan
in public school like a good school
board is worth it's weight and gold
exactly and so then the last thing that
we're looking for is candidates of good
character people who can genuinely be
role models and who can and restore that
faith in government that that people
have lost we need people who are going
to be ethical we need people who are
going to uh bring out our better better
Angels instead of trying to uh win by
appealing to our baser instincts people
who are actually trying to elevate the
conversation who are you know who are
gracious and and tolerant and maybe
Beyond tolerant compassionate who
recognizes you know other people's human
dignity and so those are those are the
kinds of characteristics that we're
looking for and in terms of policy we're
going to have a really interesting
process where we Bubble Up from the
states and from our individual Ford
members uh online what you know what
issues and what policies are most
appealing and concerning to them I think
that that is going to make us unique
among all of the policies you know among
all of the parties because you know
where else can we actually say that the
policies of a party are connected with
the beliefs and the concerns of the
members I think both the Republican
party and Democratic party have lost
contact entirely you know with their
membership so we're uh we're excited
about doing that and we're going to be
rolling that out in the next couple
[Music]
months this podcast is sponsored by
Helix sleep we sleep more than we do
just about anything anything else even
if you're hardworking you know what I
mean why sleep on a mattress that's made
for lots of people when you can sleep on
a mattress that's personalized to you
just take the quiz at Helix sleep and
get a mattress sent to you that has a
100 night trial yep 3 months and a 10 to
15year warranty my kids seek out the
Helix mattress in the house it's their
favorite one and I got to say it wasn't
made for them it was made for me don't
want to take my word for it Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine it's
going to make you healthier and more
energetic do something that's actually
going to improve your health Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com
yangang and use code Helix partner2 this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
[Music]
I obviously I mean I I love the vision
um and I'm incredibly grateful to you
for stepping into this role and for your
leadership so people have a sense of it
car's doing this for free she's doing
this out of love of country and
patriotism she's actually a donor um so
you know it's like imagine putting both
your time in and your resources in and
your relationships in and everything
else I mean that that's the kind of
leader car is uh we're incredibly
fortunate uh to have you choose forward
as a means to achieve this Vision that
you've had over the last number of years
which is to build a political home uh
for folks like you and me and Legions of
other Independents who might not agree
on everything um but certainly can agree
uh on the basics uh including the things
that you just put out and unfortunately
our two major parties are failing at the
basics right right and left I mean it
it's it's wild um you know like I come
from the Democratic party um the
Democratic part is literally talking
about championing democracy on one hand
while canceling primaries on the other
and having no debates you know I mean
like it's um we we live in a very very
difficult time um and I think that the
300 local candidates plus could be more
uh could be the Vanguard of a whole new
generation of leaders uh that might
start locally but as you say could end
up uh in Congress or in National
positions yeah I think about that that
uh I don't know whether it's a joke or a
saying uh which is you know when was
when is the best time to plant a tree
and the answer is 20 years ago you know
I wish that we would have started this
20 years ago but we need to start taking
the first steps now and I actually
believe that in another year and another
two years years this vision is very
achievable and by the time the next
presidential race comes around we're
going to be ready and we'll be able to
to field candidates all up and down the
Spectrum but I don't think that it will
ever be a lower priority for us to to
focus on those low B those down ballot
uh candidates because it's so important
it's so important that every it's always
gonna be bit of government is used for
the BET for the betterment of the
American people yeah we're we're going
to build a
like a whole ladder uh you know and and
it's uh always vital to have people
doing great work where we live um uh and
also to be developing uh the the Next
Generation and over the last couple of
years we already now have dozens of
elected officials who are affiliating
with forward uh state senators in
Pennsylvania state legislators in
Arizona May Mayors in Florida and
Connecticut and uh Colorado so we have
um already the this mini Cadre of uh of
officials and then we're going to grow
it tremendously this year uh and then if
someone turns the page on 25 when
they're looking around saying hey uh
what is forward we might be able to
point to literally at that point like
over a hundred elected officials um we
have hundreds of thousands of Americans
around the country who subscribe and are
excited many have donated thank you for
those of you who have donated we have uh
recognition in South Carolina um Utah
Florida like in in different states
around the country in different ways
like some of it's minor party
recognition um some of it's more
significant in South Carolina it's full
um you know I might be in South Carolina
as as this gets
aired but in another in another two or
three years we should have ballot access
in every state yeah exactly you know so
we we we are adding another state to our
list of places where we can have afford
candidates on the ballot every couple
months so we're um we're we're rolling
and our and our volunteers are so
excited and dedicated to what they're
doing so I we would love for anyone who
is interested in being a forward
candidate at any level uh to reach out
to us um we should have a a cool uh
forward party email address for them
right now and I'm going to make it up
and by the time this airs it's going to
be real uh candidates forp party.com
um so just email candidates forp
party.com and then that will go to the
team it's like magic digital magic
Carrie excellent so Carrie thank you for
again being an awesome leader uh and
public servant uh and operator uh I'm so
thrilled to be working with you in this
role uh we're going to build something
profound we're going to take uh your
story um and then connect it to a
million of other American stories and
then they're going to say oh wait this
is what I've been waiting for too um and
we might be just in the nick of time I
agree with you like ideal time would
have been 20 years ago um but we're here
now and uh the the country definitely
needs this more than ever yeah well well
thank you thank you Andrew and thank you
for founding forward and thank you for
bringing this group together and we are
I am deeply excited about you know the
future of this party and I'm hopeful for
the the future of America because people
are coming together to support the
democracy and the ideals that America
stands for amen Carrie you know let's go
fight for the country and for everyone
who's been volunteering for Ford or
donating or just paying attention thank
you uh do go to fordp party.com click on
your State uh there's stuff going on uh
we're hard at work and we'd love to have
you as part of the
movement